This is clearly a bus, right?
No, no, not even close!
This is obviously a Greek people-carrier.
And if you want to get around Greece in one,
better bust out your electronic calculator
and look up the roadology in a quest machine.
But if that doesn't have you all like, “huh?
what?!”, then stick around and let's take
a look at the weird, the crazy and sometimes
hilarious words that old tongues have for
talking about new technologies.
Throughout India it's incredibly common for
technical terms to come from Sanskrit, not
English.
And in Sanskrit, you can learn all about the
principles of things: the principles of chemistry,
the principles of prosperity, and even the
principles of pleasure.
Uh, hello!?
Where was that one in my university's course
catalogue?
Never one to give into the barbarians, China
has crafted some nifty tech terms.
Take the two characters in mobile phone - they
stand for "hand machine".
Clever enough, but check out this word.
Sure, it sounds like hacker, but it cleverly
slides past copyright infringement: “Hey,
we didn't steal it!
That's just our word for dark visitor!”
If you come down with a fever while speaking
Swahili in Kenya, you'll be a "person-sick"
when you visit the doctor . Let's hope they
don't diagnose you with problem of kidney,
because then they'll probably have to shred
or split you!
Turkey has made an art of ditching foreign
words and creating new Turkish ones since
the end of the Ottoman days.
(Before you get too cozy, we're talking about
the heyday of this kind of Ottoman, not this
kind of Ottoman.)
For anyone out there whose two life goals
happen to be getting to space and competing
in the Turkish Language Olympiad (yes, that's
a thing!), here's one stone for your two birds
- practice Turkish in a space vehicle.
Totally makes sense, right?
You'll then join the elite group of spacemen.
Hooray!
But you can't be totally averse to sharing
the experience with other languages, because
you're going to need things like rockets and
computer algorithms to get there.
Speaking of computers, in France and Spain
it's an ordinator.
Or is that OOORDINATORRR.
I bet you wish your comp had a name that powerful.
Nearby Italy on the other hand has no problem
just using a computer.
But not everyone in Italy is so happy to take
on new words.
The Vatican has good Latin terms for everything
from audiovisual fables to nocturnal taverns
to - my personal favorite - super spacious
airships.
Boom, there it is, a Latin jumbo jet.
You know, I bet some Roman emperors wish they'd
had one of those.
We're looking at you, Caligula... sheesh,
just what history needed, a Roman Soul Plane.
If Latin jumbo-jets can't convince you that
dead languages don't stay dead, then check
out Icelandic, where old resurrected words
dig themselves right out of their zombie Viking
graves.
Yeah, it's cool that the old word for line
came in handy again, but nothing beats booting
up your Icelandic number-prophetess.
Way to go, Iceland, you're such a make-believe
land.
As if we didn't already have proof of that
in the form of Björk and Sígur Rós.
Across the pond in the Incan Andes you can
take a class on the world order in the native
tongue.
In fact, since pacha already means time or
space, why not dig into the relations of world
things, sorry, you and this guy probably know
that as the theory of relativity.
Got your fill of physics?
Don't leave the New World yet.
First, drive north in your Blackfoot "starts
to run without apparent cause".
If that's not fast enough, the Koyukon of
Alaska might suggest an "it rises of its own
accord".
If all else fails, it's about attitude.
If you don't have a term for it, just make
the word look native.
Hawaii has this down pat.
Hawaiianizing words and phrases like ainokea
gives island imports an authentic look and
feel.
That gets us a kamepiula, assuming you don't
want to go full native and call it an electric
brain.
That's so cool.
Getting terms to sound and look more native
even if they're totally not is everyday business
in Japanese, where the locals can "box in"
foreign examples by writing them in a totally
different script - so hair dryers are hair
dryers and roller coasters are roller coasters,
even though they don't look like it at first.
Yeah, see that, that, that, that and that?
They're all from English.
Oh, hey, there's one more piece of technology
I wanted to share with you guys.
It’s called the subscribe button.
And if you just *whack*, you and I can stick
around for more technologeawsomeness in the
future.
I promise not to do the robot ever again.
Just click it, go ahead!